يوما بعد اخر يتزايد الاهتمام الدولي
بالازمه
الخليجيه السيناتور الجمهوري بوب كوركر
رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ
اعلن معارضته لصفقات بيع السلاح لدول
الخليج حتى انتهاء هذه الازمه وكان وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه ريك رسون دع الدول
المعنيه الى الحوار مشيرا الى صعوبه
استجابه قطر لبعض المطالب المقدمه اليها
من دول الحصار اما وزير الخارجيه الالماني
زيجمار جبرايل فوصفها بانها استفزازيه
للغايه ومن الصعب تنفيذها
بالكامل ترافق هذا مع دعوات دوليه للتهدئه
والحوار ايضا تقرير فتحي
اسماعيل وحدها حاله الدهشه والاستغراب
وحتى الاستنكار تخيم على مواقف العالم من
المطالب التي تضمنتها ورقه دول الحصار
المرسله الى قطر يتساءل المجتمع الدولي
ضمنا وعلنا عما اذا كانت تلك اللائحه قد
قدمت اصلا لتنفذ ام لترفض ب نظر الى انها
بدت اقرب الى التعجيز منها الى ورقه عمل
حقيقيه كما تقتضي ذلك الاعراف السياسيه
والدبلوماسيه والعلاقات بين
الدول بعد ان فعلت ذلك من قبل عندما رفضت
حصار قطر ودعت الى رفعه فورا ها هي
المانيا القوه الاوروبيه الكبرى تصف ورقه
دول الحصار بالاستفزاز جدا و بصعبه
التنفيذ في مجمل بنودها الكلام لوزير
الخارجيه الالماني زيجمار جابرييل خلال
حفل استضافه المجلس الاوروبي للشؤون
الخارجيه في برلين موقف الماني يتماهى
بالعقل والمنطق مع تصريحات لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي ريكست تيليرسون قال فيها ان من
الصعب للغايه ان تستجيب الدوحه لبعض تلك
المطالب وقد سبق لتيلرسون ان حث الحصار
على تقديم مطالب واقعيه وقابله
للتنفيذ رغم ذلك ما يزال الرجل متمسكا
بدعم الوساطه الكويتيه وبحوث الازمه وهو
ما ينسجم مع رؤيه الولايات المتحده
ومصالحها ويجعل الحرب على الارهاب اكثر
نجاعه دفاعا عن المصالح الامريكيه ايضا
المتاثره سلبا بازمه الخليج هدد رئيس لجنه
الشؤون الخارجيه في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
السيناتور بوب كوركور بعرق صفقات بيع
الاسلحه الى دول الخليج حتى حل الازمه مع
قطر واعاده توحيد مجلس التعاون الخليجي في
رسالته الى وزير الخارجيه اعتبر السيناتور
الجمهوري عن ولايه تينسي ان مجلس التعاون
لم ينتفع من القمه التي عقدها قادته مع
الرئيس دونالد ترامب في الرياض وانحدر
بدلا من ذلك الى صراع قال انه سيؤذي جهود
محاربه تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
ومجابهته ايران التي جدد رئيسها تاييد
الدوحه في الازمه الحاليه زاد وزير
خارجيتها محمد جواد ظريف على ذلك بالقول
ان تحمل قطر المسؤوليه عن الارهاب هو
محاوله من تلك الدول للتهرب من تحمل
مسؤوليه عدم تلبيه مطالب وتطلعات شعوبها
وبالتالي تفادي حاسب عن ذلك الفشل الكبير
على حد
قوله لنقاش اوسع بشان جديد الازمه
الخليجيه تنضم الينا من برلين هيلن رانج
رئيسه مجلس اداره معهد
نوموفوبيا
الخبير في السياسه الامريكيه والمدير
التنفيذي للمركز العربي في واشنطن وكذلك
نرحب بضيفنا هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور
نايف بالنهار الاستاذ في جامعه قطر نبدا
اولا مع واشنطن والدكتور جهشان
دكتور الان السيناتور كوركر تحدث عن
الحاجه لفهم افضل للطريق المؤدي للازمه
الخليجيه في الوقت نفسه اعاد هذا في يعني
توحيد مجلس التعاون فيما يتعلق باعاده
توحيد مجلس التعاون هل نفهم من هذا
الانتقاد ما بدا ربما تباين بين البيت
الابيض والخارجيه والدفاع في التعامل مع
الازمه
الخليجيه ا اكيد هذا بالفعل ما يحدث هنا
في واشنطن واعتقد ان هذه الرساله الهامه
جدا من رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في
مجلس الشيوخ وهي اعلى لجنه تشريعيه في
الواقع تشرف على سياسه الولايات المتحده
الخارجيه تثبت يعني ان النخبه الحاكمه في
مجال العلاقات الخارجيه هنا في الولايات
المتحده تبدي قلقها تجاه هذه الازمه في
الخليج ولا تتفق مع موقف الدول المحاصره
لقطر لانها طرى في بالاساس ضرر او اضرار
بمصالح الولايات المتحده في المنطقه ثانيا
بالنسبه للصراع الداخلي هنا بين وزاره
الخارجيه وزاره الدفاع وبين البيت الابيض
من الناحيه الاخرى يبدو لي ان القياده في
مجلس الشيوخ اخذت موقف منح نوعا ما لموقف
وزاره الخارجيه اكثر عقلانيه من التغريدات
التي سمعناها حول ازمه الخليج من الرئيس
ترامب قبل اسبوعين طيب نتحول الى برلين
وهلن رانج هيلن بموازاه هذا الجهد
الامريكي والمواقف الامريكيه بين اطراف
هذه الازمه وكذلك هناك الجهد الكويتي الذي
يبذل على صعيد الوساطه ماذا يمكن ان تقدم
اوروبا
الحقيقه انا اسال فيما يتعلق بالجهد
الاوروبي ماذا يمكن
للاوروبيين ان يقدموا وبتحديد
المان الاوروبيه في وجهه نظري البلدان
الاوروبيه
وبالطبع المانيا على وجه الخصوص لدينا
علاقات وثيقه مع عموم المنطقه وعليهم ان
يعملوا جميعا من اجل حل دبلوماسي لان الحل
الدبلوماسي هو الحل الوحيد وايا كان ما
يحدث حسب فهمي فان قطر تنتمي الى التحالف
الذي يحارب تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه وحسب
رايي لا ينبغي عزل قطر بهذه الطريقه ونحن
بحاجه الى حل
دبلوماسي ولا
يمكن او الاحر يجب ان الكف عن
استخدام الحدود في هذه المساله لان حدود
البلدان يجب ان تستخدم شكل الطبيعي لان
معاملته بهذه الطريقه ينتهك القانون
الدولي وحقوق الانسان واعتقد ان الكثيرين
من الالمان يشاطرون ني هذا الراي
والموقف الرسمي من وجهه نظري اننا بحاجه
الى حل دبلوماسي في اسرع وقت
ممكن
استاذ دكتور نايف الشيخ محمد العبد الله
الصباح وزير الدوله لشؤون مجلس الوزراء
الكويتي وصل الى العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن
هناك حديث في الوقت نفسه عن سعي امريكي
لدعوه اطراف الازمه الخليجيه للحوار في
واشنطن هل ثمت متغيرات جديده على صعيد
تسويه هذه الازمه هو الزياره نفهمها في
اطار انه يعني لازالت الاطراف جميعها او
ما زالت الاطراف جميعها تحترم الوساطه
الكويتيه وتقدر هذه الوساطه وترى فيها
مرجعيه لكن لا ننسى ان شراره هذه الازمه
انطلقت من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولا
ننسى ان دول الحصار ذكرت ان مطالبها وا او
شكواها في اخر مطاف سوف تسلم الى الاداره
الامريكيه وليس كما صرح بذلك وزير
الخارجيه السعودي عادل الجبير فللاسف
الشديد ان البيت الخليجي لم يعد هو الاطار
المرجعي لحل الخلاف الخليجي الخليجي ومن
هنا كان متعينا ان يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار
الموقف الامريكي وغيره من المواقف لكن
الحقيقه موقف وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
الذي صرح به امس وموقف وزير الخارجيه
الالماني كلاهما يشيران الى تقدم كبير في
الازمه الخليجيه لصالح تفكيك هذه الازمه
من خلال اللعب على وتيره الثابت المتغير
في هذا المطالب تصريح وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي وتصريح وزير الخارجيه الالماني
بينهما قاسم مشترك وعامل مشترك وهو ان
المطالب ليست كتله صلبه صماء لا يمكن
اختراقها وانما ان هناك مطالب ثابته لا
يمكن المساس بها لم يحددوا ما هي هذه
المطالب وهناك جزء من المطالب يمكن ان
تكون منطقه تساعد على تشكيل يعني ارض قضيه
مشتركه لانطلاق حوار جديد خليجي خليجي هذه
المنطقه لم تحدد ايضا ما هي خاضعه ل او
يجب ان تكون خاضعه لحوار مباشر بين
الخليجيين في الكويت بعد تسليم الرد
القطري يعني لا اعتقد ان الرد القطري
سيكون مجرد تسليم اوراق للكويت ومن ثم
الكويت تسلم لاطراف دول الحوار اعتقد انه
يجب ان يكون بعد تسليم الرد ان يكون هناك
حوار مباشر بين اطراف النزاع الخليجي حتى
تناقش ما هي المنطقه الثابته التي قطر
تمنع تماما المساس بها والتي المح لها
وزير الخارجيه الالماني والمح لها وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي حينما قال بعض المطالب
يصعب تنفيذها وما هي المطالب التي قطر قد
تقبل ب ان تكون محلا صالحا للنقاش طيب
نتحول مره اخرى للسيد الدكتور جهشان دكتور
لو عدنا الى
تصريحات بوب كوركر هذهه التصريحات جاءت
بعد يوم من تصريحات ترسون وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي بشان مطالب دول الحصار مع قطر
الان هذا الموقف لهذا الرجل في الكونغرس
الامريكي ما هي امكانيه ان يغير كثيرا في
داخل البيت الابيض من قرارات فيما يتعلق
بهذه
الازمه اعتقد ان رساله كوركر مهمه جدا
لانها يعني بالاساس ترجح كفه الميزان
لصالح وزير الخارجيه مقابل بعض المعارضه
من البيت الابيض بالنسبه اولا لتفهم
امريكي افضل للازمه وايضا محاوله يعني
الدخول في دور امريكي لتحقيق المصالحه
ا يدعم الدور طبعا الكويتي في هذا الموضوع
ومن هنا وجود الوزير الكويتي هنا في
واشنطن للتنسيق ووجود ايضا وزير
الخارجيه محمد بن عبد الرحمن بن جاسم ال
ثاني ايضا للالتقاء مع ترسن غدا
حول هذا الموضوع فاعتقد الان ان وجهه
النظر الامريكيه الطاغيه اليوم بالرغم من
معارضه ربما الرئيس ترامب شخصيا لها اصبحت
هي السياسه الرسميه المتبعه على الاقل في
هذه الفتره وخصوصا نتيجه الموقف الذي
اتخذه رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في
مجلس الشيوخ حيث لا هو يعني لا يمثل نفسه
فقط انما
يمثل اللجنه ويمثل ايضا مجلس الشيوخ ككل
ولكن يعني من تصريحات ترامب العديده التي
اطلقها بعد القمه التي عقدت في الرياض هل
من مصلحه فعلا ترامب تعليق صفقه بيع
الاسلحه مع دول
الخليج لا اعتقد ذلك ابدا بالعكس هذا يشكل
احراج شخصي للرئيس ترامب يعني هو يذهب
ويتف فاوض حول مثل هذه الصفقات ولكن
صلاحيه الموافقه على مثل هذه الصفقات هي
في يد مجلس الشيوخ في نهايه المطاف موافقه
المجلس هي الاهم من قرار الرئيس فبامكان
مجلس الشيوخ تعطيل هذه الصفقه فلذلك اقول
ان هذه الرساله تشكل اداه ضغط ليس فقط على
الاطراف المعنيه
والمحاصر لقطر بشكل مباشر انما ايضا هي
محاوله ضغط مباشر على الرئيس ترامب نفسه
شخصيا سيده هيلن يعني في قراءه للمواقف
الاوروبيه والدوليه التي نتحدث عنها هنا
يبرز ربما الموقف الماني ما قدره المانيا
في ان تقنع باقي الدول الاوروبيه بضروره
اتخاذ موقف موحد ااء هذه
الازمه
حسب وجهت نظري
فان وجهه نظر
واشنطن ليست
متحده هناك صوت يقول ان هناك حاجه الى حل
دبلوماسي
وفي في هذه المرحله ان ما حدث لم يكن من
باب الانصاف وفي هذه
المرحله حتى
عندما تستمع الى الحكومات الاخرى مثلا
موقف الحكومه الفرنسيه على سبيل مثال او
حكومه اسبانيا او حكومه
ايطاليا كل هذه الاطراف تتحدث عن ضروره حل
دبلوماسي ولكن كلهم يبدون متفقين على نفس
الموقف الا وهو انه لا يمكن حل الازمه
بهذه الطريقه سوى الحل الدبلوماسي هل لدى
المانيا قلق
مخاوف لو سمحت
لي هل لدى المانيا مخاوف من ان هذه الازمه
اذا ما استمرت ربما ستضر بكثير من
اقتصاديات الدول الاوروبيه
مثلا
يس نعم بالطبع الامر
كذلك كل اوروبا تعرف بان قطر استثمرت
الكثير من الاموال
وبالطبع خاصه المانيا على وجه الخصوص كما
[موسيقى]
تعلمون كثير من المؤسسات
الماليه
مثل بعض البنوك وشركات سيمنز وفولكس
واجن هناك اسهم في فيها تملكها قطر اذا
الوضع سيكون صعبا انه صعب الان حقيقه من
الناحيه
الاقتصاديه وهذا ينطبق على المملكه
المتحده وينطبق على فرنسا وعلى كثير من
البلدان الاوروبيه لهذا السبب ان حسب وجهه
الراي نظري علي ان اقول انا لست سياسيه
انا امثل منظمه غير حكوميه ولدي تعامل
طويل مع المنطقه والناس من امثالي لا
نستطيع ان نفهم ماذا يدور وماذا يحدث
وماذا يمكن ان يكون السبب في
ان
ان ان ان نتعامل ب بهذا انا فق انا حتى
اعصابي مثاره ولا اعرف كيف اتحدث بسبب
انني لا افهم ماذا يجري طيب دكتور نايف
بالنهار دكتور نايف بالنهار يعني في هذه
الازمه ازمه الخليج لاحظنا يعني يفترض
باطراف
الحوار هذه ان تكون رسائلهم المتبادله عبر
القنوات الدبلوماسيه و هم يعني ما زالوا
في اطار مجلس تعاون لدول الخليج العربيه
لكن يعني لاحظنا في الفتره الاخيره يعني
وزراء في دول الحصار هذه في الامارات في
البحرين يلجؤون للتعبير عبر تويتر
ا هل من تفسير لذلك مثلا هو يعني المفارقه
ان نجد بحسب ما تلوت علينا قبل قليل وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي والسناتور بوب ووزير
الخارجيه الالماني الدبلوماسيون
الاوروبيون الكبار يسعون الى التهدئه والى
راب البيت الخليجي لكن في المقابل نجد
دبلوماسيه الخليج هم الذين يصعدون يعني هل
يعقل ان تكون المطالبه بالتهدئة
يحاول ان يبث تصعيدا غير مسؤول حقيقه في
الخليج من خلال التغريدات التي دعى فيها
الى امكانيه التدخل الاقليمي في قطر انا
اعتقد ان ما وقع فيه الشيخ خالد خطا يجب
ان يعالج سريعا ويجب ان يربى راس
الدبلوماسيه البحرينيه عن الدخول في مثل
هذه المناكفات وان يحتفظ بالخط الدبلوماسي
غدا بعد تسليم الردود هناك جوله اخرى من
المفاوضات لا اقصد غدا يعني فيما سياتي من
الايام سيكون هناك جوله جديده من
المفاوضات واعتقد هذا ما يفهمه جيدا الشيخ
عبد الله بن زايد وزير الخارجيه الاماراتي
الذي صدف عن هذه المناكفات وابتعد عن هذه
الامور وترك الامر للدكتور انور قرقاش
ليمارس هذه المهمه لانه يعلم ان هناك
مراحل قادمه للعمل الدبلوماسي فبالتالي من
الخطا ان نجد دبلوماسي الخليج الكبار
يمارسون التصعيد ودبلوماسيون الغرب هم
الذين يمارسون التهدئه فيما اعتقد
المسارات القادمه قطر الحد الجوهري
بالنسبه لها انها لن تقبل اي طلب يمس
السياده وهذا امر قيل مرارا قطر لا ت بل
ان تكون نصف دوله ولا ان تكون مجرد دوله
امتداد للدول الاخرى ا ستذهب الى طاوله
الحوار لكن لن تذهبي الى طاوله يكون فيها
امر ومامور ستذهب الى طاوله فيها اطراف
يحترمون احتراما متبادلا السياده لكل دوله
لن تذهب الى طاوله فيها شخص يامر وشخص يمر
بامره هذا امر لن يمكن والا فالشعب القطري
والحكومه القطريه كلهم مستعدون لكل
الخيارات ولكل ا يعني في اقصى الخيارات في
استعداد في تاقلم نفسي لدى الشعب القطري
مع كل الخيارات ما دام ان السياده لم تمس
وكلهم كلهم شعب واحد دول الخليج اعرف صحيح
اقصد ان في النهايه لن يمارس ضغط علينا
يعني لن القطريون لن يتنازلوا عن سيادتهم
مقابل بعض اوراق الضغط التي تمارس نراها
اليوم علنا في تويتر وغير تويتر يعني هذا
الامر غير مقبول ابدا واذا كانوا يعتقدون
ان استخدام هذه الاوراق اوراق الضغط قد
تشكل يعني خرقا لنفسيه الشعب القطري
لاعاده النظر في بعض المبادئ فهذا امر
تتحدث هنا عن تماسك الجبهه الداخليه اشكرك
دكتور نايف بالنهار الاستاذ في جامعه قطر
شكرا لدكتور خليل جهشان الخبير في السياسه
الامريكيه والمدير التنفيذي لمركز العربي
في واشنطن وشكرا كذلك لهيلين ران رئيسه
مجلس اداره معهد نوف لدراسات الشرق
الاوسط ويلكم شكرا لك